hello everybody my name is Mike band I
am very excited to be here today this is
my first time speaking at the New York
our conference for those of you who
don't know me I work as an analyst for
the NFL next-gen stats team and I also
work as a data scientist for lander
analytics here in New York so today I'm
going to talk to you about my passion in
life my true love the reason why I get
up every morning sports analytics the
what I really want to get into today is
is is taught to talk about how analytics
has come so far over the last 20 years
and how finally football is catching up
to the analytical wave first let's start
with a story so the last 20 years has
been have been a revolutionary time
across all of professional sports it was
in 2003 when we were first introduced to
the concept of Moneyball and this was
led by the general manager of the
Oakland A's Billy Beane and and in 2002
the A's won 103 games despite having the
third lowest payroll in baseball now
their strategy was identifying market
inefficiencies that they could take
advantage and create competitive
advantages it was a BIOS about
identifying traits and finding value in
players that were undervalued by the
rest of the league so we fast forward
and we're still in the whole baseball
realm of analytical decision making or
of analytical support pitch FX is
introduced in 2006 in most MLB stadiums
and this was a groundbreaking
achievement in terms of tracking data
allowing you to analyze pitch speed
pitch location and it really had a big
effect on a game strategy so now we move
on to basketball and in 2007 Daryl Morey
was hired by the general as the general
manager of the Houston Rockets you might
know Daryl Morey as the founder of the
MIT Sloan sport
analytics conference so why was
basketball the next to adopt analytics
well it comes down to the lack of parity
in the league if the league has is
dominated by very few teams the need for
four to seek out competitive advantages
in any which way is very important to
building a successful team still staying
in baseball and basketball hockey and
football have not caught up yet baseball
goes deeper into the numbers and there's
no longer dollar bills available on
trees there's now nickels there's now
pennies so the so the ability to take
advantage of market inefficiencies has
declined so we started seeing more
emphasis on fielding and optimization
and lineup optimization meanwhile
basketball in the early 2010's
introduced the player tracking
technology known as sport view and this
was groundbreaking because what it did
was it it allowed for teams to to track
how much their players were working in
game how much energy they were using and
to maximize rest periods to maximize
their performance on the on the court we
finally get to hockey in the summer of
analytics in hockey 2014 this is when a
bunch of the hockey internet fanboys
became actual hockey analysts for NHL
teams it was a pretty cool summer for
hockey and in that the idea of advanced
statistics was almost universally widely
accepted to build upon the lack of I
guess you could say the lack of
explained ability of the game finally
where we finally made it to football the
last sport to embrace the analytics wave
and even those teams that were early
adopters of analytics
none of them necessarily mastered all of
all of the areas that you can apply it
was some teams mastered the salary cap
other teams focused on sports science
and player performance one team mastered
the draft and I'll get to that story in
a second so let's go back to baseball
baseball comes out with statcast
statcast technology this is new and
advanced player tracking technology
MBA comes out with identifies ways of
creating better shots and being able to
take threes and layups and dunks and the
idea of game strategy to help win games
hockey
they recently have unveiled their player
tracking technology this year and
finally the reason why we're all here
today is the player tracking revolution
in football so today I will be talking
about next-gen stats player tracking
technology and how it's changed in the
game right now so first my background
how exactly did I get here
so watching the evolution of analytics
and football has been a treat I was an
undergrad at the University of Florida
got in with the recruiting Department
they're always with a little eye on the
numbers and like Jared said I was a
little bit of an excel junkie rather
than programming I left the University
of Florida to will join the Minnesota
Vikings as a scouting assistant again
with this with an eye on the analytics
so this is the opportunity that how I
was able to meet our godfather of the
nyr Conference Jared Lander so while I
was working with for the Vikings I
received an email from Jared and and it
was he actually sent the email to the
owner it was trickled down to me and he
asked what kind of analytics are you
guys using in football and I recently
and I basically told him I go you know
we have we I had this idea is this
possible and so I basically told him I
won't we have all these data we have all
this vast amount of vast amounts of
information can we model it can we
predict who's going to be good in the
NFL Draft
we hired Jared and the rest is history
the 2015 draft was the draft at the
Vikings Ned netted trae Waynes in the
first round
Eric Kendricks in the second round to
neil hunter in the third round Stefon
Diggs in the fifth round and if you're
not football fans you might not
understand the names I'm naming but it
was a good draft I think it was the
Vikings general manager said it best
Jared in terms of analytics Jared took
us from first grade to college so back
to my background I this is when I knew
I've got to go figure out how to program
and this is my exposure to our so I
ended up going back to the University of
Chicago got my master's in analytics and
then moved on to the NFL league office
in Los Angeles so what are we going to
talk about today well today we're going
to get into the new technology behind
player tracking data the new summary
statistics we can create from the XY
data itself the primary users of the
data and where it could have the
greatest impact and finally we'll take a
small peek into the ml model that we've
built called completion probability
which is the basis for all expected
value analysis you see across other
sports so the evolution of player
tracking technology in the NFL 2014 the
NFL partnered with zebra
technologies to use RFID tags to track
XY location data during pro football
games 2015 the technology was installed
into every all 32 NFL stadiums
and began full data collection during
all preseason regular season and in
playoff games in 2016 the 32 NFL clubs
received their data in terms of their
players meaning in games they received
the XY coordinate data for only their
team not their opponent in 2017 we added
RFID chips to the ball itself so we now
create ball tracking data XY data and
really the ability to identify and
evaluate passing passing so whose lat
just last year was the groundbreaking
moment when all 32 NFL teams received
all of the data that had been collected
to that point so this was dating back to
the 2016 season and that's what
propelled the arms race that we're
seeing today in terms of the value and
using the analytics so today with the
help of AWS we are in the process of
building out multiple machine learning
models to take football analysis
to unchartered waters so how does it
work well RFID tags are placed into
every player's shoulder pads the track
consists shoulder pads not just the
shoulder pads the game ball
the first-down markers the referees the
tracking system captures XY data XY
location data at a rate of 10 times per
second
so that means there is one row per
player per play for every tenth of a
second the raw data stream contains
location coordinates speed acceleration
directions and orientation of all the
tracking chips so for example
traditionally the box score records the
following statistics for a play
traditionally in football
so nema this is a run from the AFC
championship game a very big play on
fourth and one so Sony Michell he had
one rush attempt for ten yards and one
touchdown that is all you can generate
from the from the traditional football
statistics that are recorded by the
league the official recording of the
league now we bring in next-gen stats
data you can see what essentially what
the data is collecting you can notice
the data points those are all the
players on the field and these plays are
joined together so you could sort of
understand the way that we can evaluate
now from this tracking data what can we
get out of it
we can find that Sony Michele hits 16
points 1 6 miles per hour
we know that the that the Chiefs had
nine defenders in the box meaning they
were trying to stop the run but couldn't
do it the Sony Michell gained just about
two yards per yard traveled meaning that
it was a very downhill run he got
upfield in a hurry the Patriots were in
21 personnel meaning that they were in a
run heavy or run run run look and the
Chiefs were in a three-four defense now
there's more to than just describing
with the play if you're a team you can
say you can look into the tendencies of
the Patriots and in fact when the
Patriots were in 21 personnel with with
Sony Michelle and James Devlin on the
field they ran 84 percent of the time so
situational tendencies like that that's
sort of the initial way teams can get
value out of the data so who's using the
data well we've got media and fan
engagement all 32 so this is the ability
to tell stories beyond the box score
think about when broadcasts came out
with the first down line so things like
that using tracking data to embed over
over the viewing experience will create
really a completely new a new way to
watch the game and to take in contact
content not to mention the growth of
fantasy sports and the sports betting
market the data that's created and and
and taken from next-gen stats data will
be valuable to fans and hobbyists alike
with the with the 32 NFL clubs the arms
race has begun so it will be fascinating
to see how teams leverage the data
through their everyday processes the
idea of how can we maximize performance
by modded by monitoring the player
workload both in practice and in games
how teams approach the data set towards
making their day-to-day tasks more
efficient maybe a task took four hours
to do that you can do with it with data
and analytics in about 10 minutes so
things like that how do you make your
team more efficient some will explore
how career trajectories the athleticism
how do you measure speed change the
direction reaction time all these things
are possible granted with with very deep
modeling but they're all possible in the
realm of of trying to put a number and
quantify player performance so lastly
the league office so the initiatives
that they are that they're doing at the
league how can we improve the game how
can we make the game safer how can we
change the rules how can we evaluate our
referees all these things so these are
the primary users of the next-gen test
data set so lastly I want to get into
the our our primary machine learning
model that really is the basis for how
we're going to build out future models
and conduct future analysis on our
tracking data
so the question we want to ask is what
is the probability a pass is complete
based on the characteristics of the play
more specifically if a pass is intended
to travel X amount of yards with X er
yards between the receiver and the
defender with X yards away from the
sidelines with the quarterback and
receiver travelling X amount at X speed
what is the probability the pass is
complete so what can exploratory data
analysis tell us about this problem well
one we want to do we want to improve on
the limitations on the box score
statistics we want to contextualize
passing and receiving performance on a
per play basis feature engineering is
important so we are trying to create
inputs for our model from raw tracking
data so this is essentially
understanding how can we get from raw X
Y data to actual time-stamped
event-based data to essentially create
the inputs that leverage the output and
again these features include air
distance air yards so air distances from
me to you and then air yards is from me
perpendicular to you so there's all
these different features that go into
the model are that we're going to
analyze to really understand the factors
that affect the play so a little
exploratory data analysis really trying
to understand our inputs relative to our
outputs so we first start off with air
distance so air distance is the straight
line distance of past travels so as you
can see as the distance increases our
expected our actual completion
percentage decreases now granted this is
all trained using 2016 and 2017 seasons
and we've used 2018 as our test as our
test set so air distance you can see the
the relationship there right about
anything over 40 40 yards in the air is
probably going to yield about a 30
percent completion completion percentage
receiver separation so how close the
receiver is to the nearest defender when
the pass arrives you can see the more
open a receiver is the easier it is
complete a pass this is generally most
receivers are within about three to four
yar
of the defender at the time of the cache
this is really based off of okay how can
we create open openness in our routes
and things like that pass rush
separation this is the dip the distance
between a pass rusher the nearest pass
rusher and the quarterback when it's
thrown so when a quarterbacks under
pressure you can see that his completion
percentage is low right around about 35%
but you could see when he when the
quarterback has time in the pocket he
has a much higher likelihood of
completing the pass passer speed so the
if I'm running and and I'm running and
I'm making this pass this is harder to
complete than if I were just stationary
that's what what QB speed represents in
the model and finally time to throw so
if I'm sitting in the pocket and I wait
and wait and wait the longer I wait the
less likely I complete the pass so these
are five of the main primary features in
the model there's about seven or eight
more but these had the biggest impact or
the biggest importance in the model so
what are we doing with the key modeling
considerations this is a business
problem this is not necessarily an
academic model we need to explain the
data we need to explain what the
features are doing and the effects that
they have on the output so the output we
have is binomial logistic in nature it
is either a 1 or a 0 based off of
whether or not the pass is completed we
have a nonlinear relationship between
the features in the output we know that
there might be cut-offs in the data or
cut-offs in the features that that
essentially show no more or no greater
effect on them on the model we must
account for the interactions of the
features and again we're gonna train on
2016 and 2017 and then test against 2018
data so this is what our model
validation looks like you can see that
again we're working on a Bynum binomial
logistic output so this is Bend a binned
validation plot I know that's a little
taboo in terms of your fudging the data
and making this look like an awesome fit
but at the same time this is a good
a barometer of how well our predictions
match the actual when bucketed by 5% at
each interval so what are the use cases
well we talked about how we can identify
the the probability of completed pass we
can aggregate that data and understand
how difficult a quarterback a
quarterbacks set of passes was we can
measure how well they did relative to
their expectation and get something like
completion percentage above and below
expectation this is similar to war
models that they have in other sports
the future so this is where it gets
really fun the expected value of a play
so if you were to think of continuous
problem please or completion probability
as a static variable at one that when
the pass is thrown it essentially is one
team moment in time a continuous
completion probability is the idea that
at every team moment in our time stamp
what is the probability that a pass is
complete to every receiver to every
eligible receiver on the play and what
can what this can do is it can identify
and analyze decision-making of a
quarterback when they make throws so the
idea of is a quarterback maximizing the
expected value of the play at every team
a team moment seconds and lastly how can
we design plays to leverage and maximize
our expected completion percentage and
in turn and our expected yards gained so
I'll wrap it up if you're if you're
interested in working with our player
tracking data the NFL initiated it
started initiative this year called the
Big Data Bowl it was held in
Indianapolis in February at the NFL
Combine and it featured students and
professionals getting their hands on
seven games of tracking data so this
will be coming again for the 2020 year
so keep an eye out for that as if you do
have interest in tracking data follow
next-gen stats on Twitter at next-gen
stats we have a lot of cool content and
a lot of ways to really understand
football and the data follow me on
Twitter because why not
again this is this is a new way to look
at football it's a new time in a new
wave and it's very exciting to be a part
of thank you very much
[Applause]